also ich denke auch hier sollte man
versuchen Emotionen ein wenig
rauszunehmen was die erste Frage ist was
ist long covent und auch da gibt es von
der WHU an who eine gewisse Definition
es gibt auch den Begriff des postcoweg
unter longkowitz verstanden versteht man
landläufig sozusagen Symptome die
mindestens 3 Monate nach durchgemacht
der Infektion noch da sind und auch
länger bleiben bis zu ja oder noch
länger das heißt es gibt also Menschen
die machen eine Infektion durch genesen
komplett und nach einer gewissen Zeit
entwickeln sie dann trotzdem Symptome es
gibt auch Menschen die sind schwer
betroffen die sind häufiger von dem long
kove-syndrom betroffen sind auf
Intensivstationen genesen nur teilweise
und haben sind Tour welche Symptome sind
das es geht los mit anos mi also mit mit
Riechstörungen es geht weiter über
Gedächtnisstörung kognitive
Einschränkungen und endet mit dem
schönen Begriff der fatig die werden
dann dem in der Neurologie und auch in
der normalen Presse kennen also
überbordende Müdigkeit die einen dazu
bringt nicht mehr richtig sein Ablauf zu
bewältigen wenn man ich spreche jetzt
als Neurologe aus neurologischer Sicht
natürlich gibt es andere Symptome wie
Atemnot Kurzatmigkeit das haben auch
viele Menschen die Kurve durchgemacht
haben und später dann der Triathlet der
nicht mehr seinem Sport nachgehen kann
ja die top-fitte Krankenschwester die
wie sie eben sagten dann den Schlüssel
nicht mehr im Schloss drehen kann auch
da möchte ich noch mal auf die Emotionen
ein wenig rausnehmen wichtig ist mir
dass man anerkennt dass es Symptome gibt
die uns dazu verleiten diesen diesen
Begriff des longkowitz zu geben und wir
müssen heutzutage auch von ärztlicher
Seite differenzieren was ist longkowit
genau ich als Neurologe kann Nachweise
und kann sagen es gibt Studien vermehrt
dieses Jahres in Nature veröffentlicht
dass die Symptome die das Gehirn
betreffen also die riechschwierig
Schwierigkeit
Gedächtnisstörung
merkfähigkeitsstörungen da gibt es
Korrelate im Gehirn wir können also
langsam nachweisen dass etwas ob es das
Virus ist oder eine Reaktion auf das
Virus Gehirnstrukturen verändert und zu
einer gewissen Schrumpfung in gewissen
Hirnarealen führt die genau das machen
also wir haben endlich einen korrelator
er sagen können diese Menschen die
schwer betroffen sind da können wir
sehen was sie haben aber wir wissen
immer noch nicht warum das passiert das
heißt wenn man keine richtige Diagnose
kein richtiges Verständnis hat ist es
eine Information es ist eine Infektion
mit dem Virus mit Virus Partikeln ist es
eine Reaktion darauf also das haben wir
alles noch nicht verstanden also sind
wir als Ärzte mit Symptom konfrontiert
die nicht spezifisch sind Müdigkeit gibt
es auch bei der MS Multiple Sklerose
Müdigkeit gibt es auch beim depressiven
Menschen Müdigkeit oder oder auch
merkfähigkeitsstörungen gibt es auch bei
Menschen die Drogen genommen haben die
eine Entwicklung zu einer Demenz haben
was ich damit sagen will ist es tut uns
nicht gut dass wir sozusagen jeder der
zu uns kommt jedem sozusagen dieses
diese Diagnose auch anheften wir müssen
differenzieren wir müssen andere
Erkrankungen erstmal ausschließen
solange wir nicht an Biomarker haben für
diese Erkrankung zum Beispiel für die MS
kann man sagen bei der und der
Konstellation der bildgeben und so
weiter zusammenfassen würde dann sagen
sie eigentlich das vielleicht zu schnell
da die sie Aussage ist genau weil weil
wir immer noch keine richtig wir haben
wir sind auch wenn die WHO eine
windelweiche weiß ich an das möglich ist
eine windelweiche Definition hat
tun mir keine Menschen gefallen damit
dass wir sagen so wie du dich
präsentierst das ist lancobit wir müssen
also erstmal und das finde ich das haben
wir Mediziner sind wir jedem Patienten
schuldig sicherstellen dass das wovon
wir sprechen also ihr müsst eine Katalog
also eine Entität erstmal entwickeln
dass wir sagen können mit der
Wahrscheinlichkeit hat dieser Mensch
diese Erkrankung was wir momentan machen
oder nur machen können ist wir haben
neben die Symptome und behandeln die
Symptome was ja nicht falsch ist ich bin
froh dass sie heute da sind weil ich
habe eine Pressekonferenz mit Karl
Lauterbach gesehen und mit einer
spiegelautorin und seitdem trage ich
mich ein bisschen okay wie kann ich das
jetzt selber für mich einschätzen wir
hören einmal rein
meine Infektion war im Januar ich war
dreimal geimpft also ich war ziemlich
frisch gebustert und seitdem bin ich
krank
wir klären sie sich dass sie trotzdem
so derartig erkrankt sind und
gleichzeitig werden sie auch für
Impfungen haben Sie da nicht auch einen
Zweifel dass das möglicherweise nicht so
geschützt hat wie sie sich das erhofft
haben weil sie ja trotz Impfung schwer
erkrankt
wie erkläre ich mir das keine Ahnung
kann ich mir nicht erklären also es ist
so
ich kenne auch Leute die nicht geimpft
waren und lonkovic haben von daher
also keine Ahnung wie das bei mir
gelaufen wäre wenn ich nicht geimpft
gewesen wäre also das ist nämlich die
Spiegel Journalistin Frau Stokowski
ich habe trotzdem eine Frage also als
Bürgerin schaut man sich das an und
denkt sich okay die Frau erzählt sie ist
dreimal geimpft sie ist auch gepustet
hatte Corona hat jetzt longkow wenn es
könnten aber doch dann auch Impfschäden
sein oder also ich habe gar nicht
richtig verstanden warum Herr Lauterbach
sie jetzt für die Bewerbung der Impfung
eingeladen hat mir ist es überhaupt
nicht klar geworden deswegen habe ich
mich heute so auf sie auf Sie als
Fachmann gefreut dass sie mir das mal
erklären können also ich habe Frau
Stokowski sein Beispiel einer einer
Patientin die trotz der Impfung und das
sind eher die wenigen so wie es heute
sehen also eine Minderheit trotz der
Impfung nach einer gewissen Zeit der
Genesung wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe dann Symptome entwickelt hat die
nach meine Informationen schon jetzt
täglich nachher 264 Tage anhalten also
sie hat noch die fertig das was also
diese kann sozusagen ihren Alltag nicht
be hat möglicherweise auch
merkfähigkeitsstörungen kann also nicht
mehr Texte schreiben mit der Werft wie
sie es früher gemacht hat und das ist
ein Beispiel dafür wo jetzt Impfgegner
sagen würden
ätschibachy die Impfung ist doch für ein
Eimer persönlich würde ich sagen ganz im
Gegenteil gott sei Dank ist die Dame
geimpft denn weil sie geimpft ist ist
sie nicht auf der Intensivstation
gelandet und möglicherweise verstorben
ja also das mal aus aus ärztlicher Sicht
sozusagen sie ist wahrscheinlich eine
der und wir haben das das Syndrom immer
nicht verstanden wir verstehen immer
noch nicht warum Karl lauterbachstelle
als testimoni für die Impfung
mitgenommen nein ich sage also sie ist
kein gutes Beispiel dafür weil die weil
sie trotz Impfung was aber vielen
passiert die Infektion durchgemacht hat
und leider dann auch und das wissen wir
dass eine Minderheit dann obwohl sie
geimpft sind und diese die also erkrankt
sind trotzdem dann das was wir als
longkowith betrachten entwickeln können
das bedeutet aber im Umkehrschluss nur
dass wir noch nicht genau verstehen
wieso das so ist wieso wieso also und
das versuchen wir zu verstehen das ist
immer noch early days wir sind noch ganz
am Anfang gehen also man könnte ja
vereinfacht sagen der der schwer
erkrankt ist hat ein größeres Risiko
nein nicht mehr ganz kurz ich will alle
Argumente am Tisch hören ansonsten sieht
die ganze Zeit dran Frau Bosbach da bin
ich ziemlich gerne mal fragen also es
sind die Early Days wir sind ganz am
Anfang in der Kommunikation klingt das
aber ja eigentlich so als wüssten Ärzte
Politiker alle alles weil sonst können
sie uns ja nicht alles empfehlen wie
fühlen sie sich denn abgeholt als Bürger
als Bürger genau das ist der Punkt jetzt
nicht treffender sagen kann ich habe ein
riesen Problem mit der Kommunikation und
zwar von Minute eins an das hatten wir
eben schon ähm genau das ist das Problem
was man gar nicht wo man anfangen soll
auch mit der Impfkampagne das war ich
habe mich auch impfen lassen komplett
gar keine Frage obwohl jetzt sage es war
keine Frage weil es war für mich war
eine Frage und genau aus diesem Grund
weil ich mich überhaupt nicht aufgeklärt
gefühlt habe weil ich zu denjenigen
gehört habe soll ich eine sehr sehr
große Gruppe an Menschen gewesen gesagt
haben wir sind keine Schwur bla keine
Leugner keine Skeptik aber wir dürfen
doch mal kritisch nachfragen wenn diese
Fragen nicht beantwortet werden
man das nicht gerade das Vertrauen in
bestimmte Maßnahmen das gleiche was wir
eben gehört haben wie geht man denn dann
wieder der Punkt wie gehst du denn damit
etwas um Beispiel hier mit dem wir
wissen wir haben attestiert bekommen von
ärztlicher Seite es gibt im Schäden die
reagierst du denn dann als Starter drauf
musst doch vertrauensbildende Maßnahmen
schaffen du musst die Leute doch mit
irgendwelche Eingreifen es gibt
Strukturen wenn man den Verdacht eines
Impfschadens hat als als Bürger als Arzt
wo man sich melden
Argument dass dagegen
aber ehrlich gesagt sie sagen auch wir
sind bei den Early Days aber wir wissen
trotzdem so und so und so und die
Impfung macht man ab 60 und so weiter
deswegen Frau Bosbach erklärt einfach
nur mal wie sie die Lage sieht danke so
stinkt das hätte ich jetzt so und jetzt
ist und nochmal es geht ja gar nicht
darum und wenn das so lange dauert dann
ist es doch auch eine Art der
Kommunikation das doch wenigstens mal
dazu legen wenn du mauerst kommunikativ
von Seiten der Reg also alles was
intransparent ist es per se schon mal
schlecht so da spürst du lediglich
Protest mit bei den Bürgern oder Unmut
im besten Fall wir wollen doch
eigentlich genau das Gegenteil erreichen
mir ist doch viel lieber jemand geht von
vornherein hin und sagt wir wissen nicht
alles wir empfehlen es euch aber aus
grünen ABCD jetzt entscheidet du bitte
selber ich glaube dass das wesentlich
weniger Reaktanz verursacht als die Art
und Weise wie es nun mal kommunikativ
geschehen ist auch jetzt wäre es mir
lieber man sagt wir stehen ganz am
Anfang überlegt es euch trefft ihr die
Entscheidung alles was auf Zwang ist und
dann mit diesem Stadium das man ja kennt
eben da das ist ja gar gestern ein
normales natürlich dass man am Anfang
Entschuldigung reden sie von den
Politikern die oder reden sie also ich
möchte nur erinnern Herr Drosten kennt
die noch jemand Herr Drosten hat einen
Herz der der Virologe natürlich also
wenn Sie Herrn Drosten kennen der hat
einen Podcast gemacht der hat auch ganz
ehrlich gesagt der Wissenschaft gibt es
verschiedene Meinung ich fand
persönlicher sehr gut wie ich sag mal
Herr Drosten kommuniziert hat ich fand
auch gut dass viele Politiker auch schon
gesagt haben wir wissen auch nicht wie
es weitergeht wurde die
einrichtungsbezogene
Entscheidungen
von von Stunde Null an ist man sofort
sofort mit
gewaltvollzogen Impfpflicht gut finden
dafür sind wir bei 8:15 Uhr jeder darf
das empfinden wie er